même en tension à cause des difficultés
quand contre le trafic de drogue et pas
que le trafic de drogue d'ailleurs un
tout une partie des jeux aux activités
délictuelles qui se déroule dans ces
quartiers c'est assez compliqué pour moi
mais il faut bien comprendre que je
parle évidemment pas de la population
des quartiers le parle de cette minorité
qui crée des désordres dans les
quartiers mais qui est la minorité qui
occupent occupe une partie des parkings
qui occupent ou partie des voix cette
minorité l'a elle même est en difficulté
parce que l épée liées à l'économie à
l'économie un camp tout à l'économie
criminelle les quartiers et cette partie
là de la population on est à cran pour
mac est l expression je n'ai entendu
mais c'est vrai elle est à prendre
et donc comme souvent le moindre
incident provoque le sitho une
réactivité une réaction assez important
parce que ces quartiers sont toujours
éruptif 7 mo ti l'instant et un accident
de moto relativement banal convenons-en
à le garçon en question qui est
d'ailleurs un garçon qui est un homme de
30 ans on n'est plus un jeune homme
et à une jambe fracturée c'est pas un
accident majeur
mais la situation est tellement éruptif
qui suffit que l'incident fois connu et
évidemment la communication passe très
vite d'un endroit à l'autre pour que
pour susciter des réactions qui sont des
réactions collectives etc c'est ça qui
fonde les les émeutes et les violences
urbaines sur lesquels je travaille
depuis 30 ans maintenant c'est à chaque
fois un fait générateur ou vent qui dans
lesquelles la police est présente parce
que c'est souvent interprété comme une
agression de la police à l'égard des
jeunes et se fait générateur qui ensuite
au nom de la solidarité des quartiers
fini par générer des violences
collectives dans plusieurs quartiers la
fois donc c'est exactement le même
à partir d'un incident qui ne s'en
doutait le mouvement aurait pas gérer
cette violence mais c'est parce que les
quartiers sont sous tension
qu'aujourd'hui cette violence est plus
grande
[Musique]